die nasa selbst spricht davon dass
dieser plan die gesamte raumfahrt
revolutionieren könnte denn durch einen
nuklearen antrieb würde sich die
reisezeit von langzeitmissionen wie etwa
zum mars enorm reduzieren und das
wiederum würde das gesundheitliche
risiko für astronauten astronauten
drastisch senken klicks um
science-fiction gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und activity glocke nur dann
verpasst den nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen eine reise zum mars würde
nach schätzung von fachleuten nur noch
drei bis vier monate dauern wenn
raumschiffe sich durch nukleare antriebe
fortbewegen würden auf dem treffen des
national space council msc sprach der
nasa chef jim ryan von dem nächsten
riesenschritt der menschheit durch
nukleare technologie der nächsten
generation der rat nsc wurde 2017 von us
präsident donald trump wieder eingesetzt
um die weltraumpolitik der usa zu
steuern wichtig bei alldem der nukleare
wärme antrieb der derzeit im gespräch
ist ist nicht zu verwechseln mit dem
bereits bestehenden radioisotopen
generatoren rpgs die die nasa seit
jahrzehnten einsetzt hier wird wärme
durch den radioaktiven zerfall von
plutonium erzeugt die dann in
elektrizität umgewandelt wird dadurch
können dann geräte und raumfahrzeuge
instrumente angetrieben werden
beim nuklearen wärme antrieb wird durch
die kernspaltung wärme erzeugt die dann
wiederum treibstoff wie wasserstoff mit
krasser geschwindigkeit verbrennt also
quasi ein kernreaktor wie in einem u
boot oder einen großen kriegsschiff das
würde die reisezeit von
langzeitmissionen sogar halbieren
dadurch würde eine reise zum mars nur
noch halb so lange dauern und das hätte
enorme vorteile für die besatzung denn
vor allem die schädliche strahlung im
all stellt ein hohes risiko für
astronauten und astronauten dar und kein
raumschiff dieser welt kann diese
gefährliche strahlung so gut abhalten
wie sie atmosphäre die ozonschicht und
das magnetfeld der erde tun
auf der iss der internationalen
raumstation ist das weniger ein problem
weil das erdmagnetfeld einiges davon
bereits weiter außen ab hält die iss
kreist nur in einer höhe von 400
kilometern um die erde
mars missionen die demnächst angepeilt
werden bedeutet aber auch dass die
besatzung eine große strahlendosis
abbekommt und fest steht sie kann das
menschliche gewebe und nervenzellen
tatsächlich schädigen
da sie die aluminiumhülle des
raumschiffes durchdringt medizin teams
befürchten dass die strahlung deutliche
auswirkungen auf die astronauten
astronauten haben könnte beispielsweise
könnten die emotionale stabilität und
die reaktionsfähigkeit nachlassen aber
auch das krebsrisiko steigt durch die
strahlung forschungsteams weltweit sind
dabei medikamente zu entwickeln die die
wirkung der kosmischen strahlung
abfedern könnten beispielsweise in dem
die menschlichen zellen strahlen
resistenter gemacht werden nach der
einschätzung von experten und
expertinnen ist jedenfalls klar diese
strahlung stellt eine der größten
gefahren bei einer marsmission da durch
eine verringerung der reisezeit würde ja
aber auch die strahlen dosis verringert
werden dazu jim wittenstein das ist
absolut wegweisend für das was die nase
erreichen will dieser plan ermöglicht es
uns das leben bei der reise zwischen
erde und mars wirklich vor der strahlung
zu schützen
doch auch für waffensysteme würde der
einsatz von nuklearen antrieb von
raumschiffen diskutiert raumschiffe die
in der nähe der erde kreisen könnten
somit schneller denjenigen
waffensystemen ausweichen die installer
abzielen laut josef mega ein
hochrangiger regierungsbeamter der
vereinigten staaten werden solche waffen
von russland und china bereits
entwickelt demnach könnten diese im
kriegsfall einen angriff auf us
amerikanische und alliierter
raumfahrtsysteme staaten diskutiert
wurde auch ein solcher nuklearer antrieb
auch bezüglich der abwehr von asteroiden
durch die entwicklung eines
hochleistungs lesers könnte zudem auch
die zerstörung von weltraumschrott
möglich werden finanzielle hilfen hat
die nasa jedenfalls schon für das
projekt bekommen
alleine 125 millionen us-dollar sollen
laut einem aktuellen gesetzentwurf
bereitgestellt werden um nukleare
antriebstechnik ihn zu erforschen der us
kongress stellte zudem weitere 100
millionen us dollar in diesem jahr
bereit und so wundert es nicht dass kein
einziges wort über die gefahren eines
nuklearen antriebssystems in der
raumfahrt verloren wurde
dabei ist das risiko einer radioaktiven
kontaminierung also verseuchung nicht
von der hand zu weisen falls ein solches
raumschiff mal abgeschlossen wurde oder
aus einem anderen
und auseinander bricht also eine ganz
neue dimension von weltraumschrott wie
funktioniert der hyper antrieb anklicken
anschauen und unbedingt supercooler
kanal asto comics tv abonnieren bis dann
bleibt dran